(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] See.
Have y'all met before?
- Never, never but-
- No.
- You have reposted some of
the vids like when I've been on
playing you on the show.
- Oh, well of course.
I mean, what an honor.
- I was like, "Whoa."
- I always say you made
it if somebody like-
- Is yeah, imitating you.
- dresses up for Halloween
as you and makes fun of you so
- Yeah, yeah. No, I think you've made it
'cause you're in their
mind. You're in their...
You do impressions a lot though, right?
- Yes, yes.
- And you did,
you did Gwen?
- Yeah.
- I don't know thi-
I have never seen this.
What's your Gwen impression?
- So I
if No Doubt comes on the radio
or Gwen you come on the radio
and I'm driving, it is
dangerous 'cause I get so into
your impression and it's not safe.
I can't drive. I'm driving just like a
(Melissa singing)
Beep beep.
- [Kelly] Beep beep.
(everyone laughing and cheering)
Beep beep. (laughing)
- And it's kind of that
old, I mean like the-
- Do that again.
- Can you just do it again?
- Yeah.
♪ You're really lovely ♪
♪ Underneath it all ♪
- I just love this song.
It's one of my favorites.
I love that.
- Thanks guys.
- Do you like how I'm so annoying,
I couldn't not be a part
of it then I was just like,
"I love this song."?
- No, go ahead.
- Yeah, I love it.
- Get in the car
with me.
- You're really good at it.
No, you're really good at impressions
so who else have you done?
- I mean, I've done Dolly Parton.
That's a everyone's fav.
- Wait, I wanna see Dolly.
- Yeah.
- How did you do Dolly?
- Oh my God.
- Oh my gosh, yes.
So I, and that's a voice
I use whenever I need to
pump myself up with
affirmations in the morning,
I'll be like, "I am so
beautiful. I am lovable.
I am capable."
- Capable. (laughing)
- And I love the new song that you,
I mean the nine to five
- Oh, thank you.
you guys did.
- Yeah.
- It's beautiful.
- Dream like come true.
Three pointer.
- Whoo.
- Yeah.
- That-
- I didn't even know
what it was, by the way,
they were like, "You wanna
do a song with Dolly?" Yep.
Didn't need to hear it.
- And I love that
she's in the back going
- Yeah.
nine to five.
- Yeah, yeah.
It sounds like she's
like, it's like nostalgia.
Yeah, I love it.
- It's so good.
- It was a dream come true.
I love that you do Dolly,
you do all the greats.
I like (indistinct)
- I mean-
- You take 'em on.
- Well it's just,
it's truly people that are
that I get obsessed with and inspired by
and I listen to over
and over and just become
them.
- 'Cause that's the flattery.
You have to, to be able
to match the sound,
you have to have listened to it so much.
- Oh yeah.
- So it's so flattering,
- Yeah.
- in that sense.
- Oh, yeah.
- Well, that's cool.
Okay so wait, now you
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] have a new
book and this is maybe
my favorite title of any
book ever, it's called
"Whoops... I'm Awesome."
- Whoops.
- [Kelly] Will you tell us about it?
I love this title.
- Yes.
- It's so great.
So I'm a really emo person
okay. I'm a comedian,
I'm a joker but I do have
a really sensitive side
so I draw and I've made
this art Instagram called
"Melissa V Art", really simple title.
And I've been sharing the past five years,
just my drawings and people,
my fans have just grown
there and I love it.
It's really emotional and cathartic for me
and yeah.
- I love that.
- But the book is all like
kind of a workbook activities,
but it's silly too.
- So you offer some advice in the book
like mailing letters.
- Yeah.
- So do you really,
I love handwritten letters.
- I heard.
- Yeah.
- I do like writing letters
'cause I feel like you're
thinking about the person
and you're meditating on 'em
as you're writing.
- Yeah.
- And I think people love
letters, when they get 'em
in the mail, they're like, "Oh boy."
And you wanna sit and read.
- It's special
'cause it doesn't happen anywhere.
You feel like you're at
Hogwarts or something,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like a tale of,
nobody does it anymore.
Nobody does any handwritten
or anything. We're always
texting, there is something
special about it. Do
you ever write letters
or do you ever do anything like that
like old school anymore?
- I'm dyslexic so I just sort of don't
but you've referenced Hogwarts.
You're such a fan
of Harry Potter.
- I'm such a fan of magic.
- Oh my God. Is anyone
is this in your mind?
- Literally this look,
right now, it's kind of-
- I'm trying to get a job,
if there's another film.
This is me preparing
for my witch role.
Yeah. No, I love anything magical or...
You know why? I like to escape
like what reality is sometimes
- Yeah.
- because reality, even
though it's cool sometimes,
it's fun. God gave us an imagination
or whoever you believe
did but something gave us
an imagination and that's incredible.
What you can create
- Yeah.
- in your head, I sound crazy
- No.
- right now.
- I get it.
I get it.
- I just think it's awesome and art,
that's where art comes from,
is our imagination.
- Most of my drawings,
at night they pop up in my
brain and then I write it down.
I wake up then I write down
- That's like songs.
- the idea and then when
I get to it, I draw it
but I really,
a lot of 'em just come from
- Yeah.
- that dream place.
- Yeah, I'm a 40 year old who
totally loves magic (laughs)
and I'm not, I'm not...
Whatever, it is what it is.